♪ ♪
>> Greg: ONCE THE FACE OF HARD
NEWS, CNN IS THE OF AMERICA'S
JOKES.
THE LATEST AUDIO, CHRIS CUOMO
CONSPIRES OVER PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
APPEARANCE.
YES, HE LOOKS EXACTLY THE SAME
SINCE HE BECAME PRESIDENT AND
THAT CAN'T BE GOOD.
>> LOOK AT PRESIDENTS WHEN THEY
COME IN AND WHEN THEY LEAVE.
I MEAN, COME ON.
CLINTON'S HAIR.
GEORGE W. BUSH LOOKS LIKE HE GOT
A BEAT DOWN.
OBAMA LOOKS LIKE HIS OWN
GRANDFATHER.
LOOK.
THIS IS A VERY HARD JOB BECAUSE
OF THE STRESS THEY CARRY WITH
THEM.
NOW LOOK AT THIS PRESIDENT.
IT'S BEEN ALMOST THREE YEARS
SINCE TRUMP WON THE PRESIDENCY.
HE LOOKS EXACTLY THE SAME.
HIS HAIR, I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON BUT HE MAY DO THINGS
PRESIDENTS IN THE PAST HAVE BEEN
DONE TO AUGMENT THEIR PHYSICAL
REALITY.
BUT IT COULD ALSO BE THAT HE
DOESN'T CARE THE WAY OTHERS
HAVE.
>> Greg: ONLY ON THE CLONE
NEWS NETWORK AND AN ANCHOR
WONDER IF THE PRESIDENT IS
AUGMENTING HIS PHYSICAL REALITY.
IN OTHER WORDS, WHAT THE HELL
DOES THIS MEAN?
SINCE THEY RUN OUT OF WAYS TO
SAY TRUMP IS CRAZY, THEY HAVE
MOVED ON TO SAY HE SOMEHOW
MAGICALLY STOP THE AGING
PROCESS.
MPI WOULD LEAVE THE PARANORMAL
ANALYSIS TO EXPERTS IN CROP
CIRCLES.
YOU HAVE TO WONDER HOW MUCH CNN
PAYS FOR THIS POLITICAL
ANALYSIS.
>> I AM THE CHOSEN ONE HE SAYS,
AFTER THE PRESIDENT REACH WEEDED
OF CONSPIRACY THEORIST RADIO
HOST WHO SAID HE'S LIKE THE
SECOND COMING.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE ALL THIS?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Sandra: I THINK MAYBE HIS
MOMMY SHOULD'VE TOLD HIM SHE
LOVED HIM A LITTLE BIT MORE.
IT'S HARD TO KNOW.
>> Greg: HARD TO KNOW.
SOMEONE HAS A FUTURE IN ONLINE
PSYCHOLOGY.
TELL US WHY CHRIS CUOMO IS SO
ANGRY.
TALK ABOUT NEVER AGING, SHE
LOOKS GREAT.
ONLY CNN COULD FRAME NOT AGING
IS A BAD THING.
IMAGINE TRUMP WAS SHOWING HIS
AGE.
CUOMO WOULD SAY THE JOB WAS
WEARING HIM DOWN SO MUCH.
SERIOUS THREAT TO SURVIVAL OF
OUR REPUBLIC.
TRUMP LOOKS THE SAME AS HE DID
ONE TOOK OFFICE.
TOO BAD YOU CAN'T SAY THE SAME
FOR CNN.
>> Jesse: CUOMO TOAST.
IT'S A GOOD ONE.
>> Greg: IS IT?
I WILL KEEP IT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: GREG, IF YOU ARE
MARRIED TO MELANIA, YOU WOULD
PROBABLY HAVE THAT YOUTHFUL LOOK
TOO.
>> Greg: ARE YOU SAYING
SOMETHING ABOUT MY WIFE?
>> Jesse: NO!
YOU LOOK GREAT.
MAYBE IT'S THE PEACE AND
PROSPERITY GLOW.
THERE'S NO WARS, NO RECESSION.
NOT AGING HIM THAT BAD.
YOU DON'T REALLY SEE THE
DIFFERENCE.
TRUMP 2016 AND TRUMP 2024, YOU
COULD DO A DO A SIDE BY SIDE.
>> Greg: THE BEGINNING OF HIS
THIRD TERM.
>> Jesse: EXACTLY.
WHEN TRUMP WAKES UP IN THE
MORNING, HE DOESN'T EVEN
REMEMBER WHAT HAPPENED THE DAY
BEFORE BECAUSE HE DOESN'T LET
ANXIETY AND NEGATIVITY WAY DOWN
THE WAY AND ALL-PRO NFL
QUARTERBACK, THAT'S HOW THEY
SCOUT THESE GUYS.
YOU WANT A GUY WHO GETS BURNED
FOR A 50-YARD PASS ON THE NEXT
SNAP HE IS STILL UP THERE WITH
SWAGGER, FORGOT ABOUT THE LAST
PLAN IS STILL TALKING TRASH AND
THAT IS DONALD TRUMP.
>> Juan: UNLIKE GLORIA, YOU
SHOULD GET AN AWARD FOR
ANALYSIS.
TRUMP GETS BURNED ON EVERY PLAY.
DOESN'T SEEM TO MATTER.
THEN WHEN HE GETS EMBARRASSED
AND THE MEDIA REPORTS, YOU SAY
THE MEDIA IS TERRIBLE.
WHY ARE THEY SAYING THAT HE
TALKED ABOUT GREENLAND AND THEN
SAID WHY WOULD ANYBODY CALL THAT
ABSURD, BUYING GREENLAND.
>> Greg: TRUMAN.
TRUMAN, IT WAS A DEMOCRAT IDEA.
>> Juan: THERE'S NO RECESSION.
THE ECONOMY IS GREAT.
TAX CUTS AND JEROME POWELL, CUT
RATES?
>> Judge Jeanine: THE AMAZING
PART IS THEY WOULD RATHER HAVE
THE PRESIDENT ACT LIKE MUELLER
WHO DOESN'T REMEMBER OR KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT WHAT HE WAS
WORKING ON FOR THE LAST TWO
YEARS, OR JOE BIDEN WHO DOESN'T
OF THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN TRUTH
AND FACT.
THAT'S WHAT THEY WANT.
IF SOMEONE IS A CERTAIN AGE,
THEY SHOULD JUST BE STUPID?
HERE'S THE BOTTOM LINE.
800 POINTS, EVERYBODY WENT NUTS.
YOU AND I BOTH KNOW IT'S THE
ANIMAL INSTINCT THAT DECIDES HOW
WE GO FORWARD IN THE ECONOMY.
800 POINTS.
WE CAME BACK IMMEDIATELY.
ALL RIGHT, SO EVERYTHING IS FINE
IN TERMS OF THE ECONOMY, IN
TERMS OF OUR BEING SAFE.
THEY JUST WANT TO BE CRAZY.
HE'S NOT.
HE'S USED DISTRESS.
HE'S NOT A POLITICIAN.
HE DIDN'T COME UP THE EASY WAY
THEY READ THE REST OF THEM DEAD.
>> Sandra: HE DOESN'T DRINK,
HE DOESN'T SMOKE.
>> Greg: YES.
THAT'S THE POINT.
EVERYBODY WHO I KNOW WHO DOESN'T
DRINK HAS TOO MUCH ENERGY FOR M
ME.
>> Sandra: AND THAT'S A LIE.
>> Greg: MY FRIENDS WHO DON'T
DRINK, THEY ARE OVERPOWERING
WITH ENERGY.
>> Juan: HIS PROBLEM HE
DOESN'T SLEEP EITHER.
HE'S TWEETING.
>> Jesse: HE'S WORKING FOR US,
JUAN.
EVEN YOU.
>> Judge Jeanine: DOESN'T NEED
TO DO IT, THAT'S THE BIG POINT.
HE DOESN'T NEED TO BE PRESIDENT.
HE COULD BE PLAYING GOLF.
>> Greg: SANDRA, YOU RAISED A
GOOD POINT.
DO YOU THINK IF HE WERE A WOMAN,
LIKE A KIND OF DID WITH GLORIA
>> Sandra: I DON'T KNOW HOW
IT'S RELEVANT TO THE PERFORMANCE
ON THE WORK HE'S DOING.
THE THOUGHT HAS CROSSED MY MIND,
HE -- YOU GO BACK TO THE BUSH
AND OBAMA YEARS, PRESIDENTS DO
AGE.
FOR FUN FOR THE SEGMENT, I
LOOKED AT THE OPRAH INTERVIEW IN
1988.
HE HASN'T CHANGED MUCH AT ALL.
HIS PHYSICAL APPEARANCE.
>> Jesse: THE DOCTOR'S NOTE?
THE HEALTHIEST MAN ON EARTH?
DOCTOR'S ORDERS.
YOU'VE GOT TO LISTEN TO MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS.
>> Greg: THERE IS A DECADE
WHERE YOU TEND TO AGE.
OBAMA, IT'S WHEN YOU GO GRAY.
THE SAME TIME HE WAS PRESIDENT.
IT WASN'T LIKE IT WAS THE
PRESIDENCY.
>> Juan: GREGORY, I HAVE AN
IDEA.
REMEMBER WHEN THERE WAS THAT
CONSPIRACY THEORY ABOUT THE
WIFE, THAT IT WAS NOT MELANIA
BUT A BODY DOUBLE?
I THINK MADAME TUSSAUDS HAS
PROVIDED A BODY DOUBLE FOR
TRUMP.
>> Greg: I WILL SAY CUOMO IS